Bonjour ! Comment vous allez ? Moi ça va extrêmement bien ! Clément ça va ?
- Ça va!
- On s'en fout.
Aujourd'hui on va jouer à quoi ?
Aaah...euh... démêler les câbles... C'est faux !
Aujourd'hui on va jouer à Bloody Mary
C'est un jeu dans lequel nous incarnons un enfant de 11 ans en pyjama rayé très très beau
le même que t'avais mis hier soir pour dormir !
Fais pas genre !
On va se poser devant le miroir de la salle de bain comme ça,
et on va faire ce qu'on a tous voulu faire quand on avait 11 ans :
Dame blanche, Dame blanche, Dame blanche, devant le miroir, à minuit,
en espérant qu'elle vienne... Mais pas trop !
C'est parti ! Invoquons...
Bloody Mary !!
Alors !
On a donc un...
Bon je rame déjà ! Je sais pas pourquoi ça rame !
Voilà !
On a donc un téléphone et des bougies ! Je suppose qu'il faut éteindre la lumière...
*cris viriles* ATT...ATTENDS MEC !!
J'ai crus que c'était l'interrupteur j'ai carrément mis les doigts dans la prise !
*rires*
J'vais me tuer !!
Où est l'interrupteur de cette salle de bain ?
Et pourquoi cette porte fait 8m20 ?
Où est l'interrupteur ?
Y'a bien... Ohhh bon vas-y t'sais quoi on va allumer... En même temps faut allumer les bougies avant je pense !
Ahhh ! D'accord nickel !
Il perd pas d'temps, c'est parfait, on y va !
Okkk...
Ça c'est éteint tout seul...
Et du coup ça lague plus !
Tu me crois ?
En fait quand tu lague sur un jeu faut éteindre la lumière !
Bon voilà, c'était le bilan de cette vidéo...
Ok j'ai allumé les bougies...
Ok qu'est-ce qui ce passe ?
Ahh ça s'éteint ?
Ça va venir de la fenêtre c'est sûr !
Tu paries combien ?
Je peux pas allumer la radio pour me rassurer ?
Tu sais mettre NRJ ? Tomber sur le.. la nouvelle chanson de JUL ?
*bruits flippants*
AHHHHH !!!
Ça a bougé derrière !
Ça a bougé derrière le rideau !
C'est bon y'a rien à travers, j'ai regardé y'a rien !
*rires*
Je préfère pas l'ouvrir !
*bruits de vent*
Ohhh?... C'est quoi ça ?
Ohhlala....
On dirait une autre dimension, mec !
AHH !!
OHHHH !!
OOHH !!!
WOOOH !!
Faut que je rallume ! Faut que je rallume ! Faut que je rallume !
Faut que je rallume ! C'est bon !
C'est bon, on est bon ! Je suis protégé !
Ah c'est... t'as vu mec ? Ça l'a fait dégager !
T'as vu le bon réflexe que....
Ah ah ah ! Il a une gueule horrifiée !
Qu'est-ce qui ce passe ?
Elle revient ?
AHH !
Ohhh !!
Elle est grande, mec !
Faut qu'j'rallume les bougies !
J’arrête pas d'rallumer les bougies !
Ça fait beuger le jeu !
Ah ah ah !
*rire démoniaque*
Euhh...
Alors attends.. peut-être dans les tiroirs y'a des choses, mec ?
Ah y'a une lampe-torche dans un tiroir !
Dans l'autre tiroir y'a un bouquin, y'a un bouquin
t'sais va falloir réciter un truc genre :
"Satanas ripoli catis"...
C'est du latin, hein !
Bon mec, j'ai lu le livre et ils disent rien de fou dedans !
Donc, après, ce que j'ai d'autre c'est..
Ahh y'a un cadenas là dessus !
J'pense qu'il faudrait réussir à ouvrir le cadenas !
Et là dedans on va avoir quelque chose d'utile..
mais du coup, où est la clé ? C'est ça la question !
Bon déjà ce qu'on va faire, mec, j'pense on va prendre la light.
Là y'a rien, là y'a rien, ici j'ai...
Ah peut-être dans la poubelle, la clé c'est une bonne cachette !
C'est une idée de merde mais bon !
C'est moi qui ai mis le livre dans la poubelle ?
Non c'est un 2e livre, ça !
C'est un 2e livre !
C'est un 2e livre !!
Attends faut juste 2 secondes,
que je fasse ça...
Hop, hop..
Hop, hop... Voilà !
Alors
"Hey everybody ! I've got a song to sing !"
Ah ok, en fait c'est les paroles d'une chanson, juste !
C'est juste les paroles d'une chanson.. Euhh..
C'est nul à chier !
Ça m'aide pas du tout !
Ok re ! Cette fois on va réussir !
En gros le but, j'avais pas compris, mais c'est d'la buter !
Toi tu l'invoque pour faire un petit.. une petite goutte dans caleçon,
Lui vraiment il est à... la step du dessus !
On allume toutes les bougies !
OK !
Madame est une maligne, elle va vouloir arriver,
par la fenêtre qui est là !
Clément, on panique pas !
Si tu panique, je vais paniquer, tu paniques pas !!
Voilà y'a le rideau qui bouge...
On brûle le rideau...
Maman appelle les pompiers, fin du jeu.
Le téléphone sonne, j'réponds avec l'allumette
Parce-que, après être résistant à l'eau les téléphones sont résistant à quoi ?
Aux flammes
Ça marche pas
La fenêtre s'ouvre, Bloody Mary rentre et elle éteint les bougies
Et pour ne pas mourir, ce qu'il faut faire c'est rallumer les bougies
La on attend qu'elle rentre... Vas-y rentre, mets toi bien...Vas-y cousine !
METS TOI BIEEEN ! Mets toi bien !
On ferme la fenêtre
HOP
Et on allume les QUATRE bougies !
Et la qu'est ce qu'elle fait ? Elle va se réfugier dans le miroir ... Normalement.
là elle est zob, là elle est zob.
Le miroir se baisse...
ELLE SORT DES CHIOTTES
MERDE , c'est pas prévu , C'est pas prévuu !
Faut fermer la cuvette !
Euh les bou.. les bou..gies , On rallume les bougies oui
AH JE SAIS ! Tirer la chasse ! Tirer la chasse !
*Bruit de chasse d'eau* HOUHOU *Rire et soulagement viril à la fois*
Ça a marché ou pas ?
Non je crois pas...
Donc la elle vient, HOP ça dégage
OH ! c'est bon ça a marché mec !
Fallait attendre un petit peu, tirer la chasse, et elle m'a lâché une clef
Une clef qui va servir à quoi ?
à ouvrir le cadenas qu'il y a la ... Ah non c'est qu'une moitié de clef c'est ça !
J'ai qu'une moitié ?
é..é...elle est pas la dedans l'autre moitié de clef ?
WOH
Oh mec ça saigne hein dans la baignoire hein ! Ça se remplit de sang hein ?
Peut-être le PQ ? Lui envoyer le PQ ?
T'sais y'a du sang de ouf, ptêtre faut..
Boh je sais pas. J'suis dans la propa la
OH LA PORTE S'EST OUVERTE !
NAN
NAN , c'est pas censé s'ouvrir ! c'est pas censé s'ouvrir.
Merde merde merde merde merde merde merde
Voooila c'est bon c'est bloqué. Elle est où ?
TIG *Clef qui tombe*
OUI c'est bon ! J'ai la deuxième clef, fallait juste bloquer la porte putain je le savais Clément !
Ok le cadenas a dégagé *Ampoule qui casse*
OH BAH OUI ! On perd pas de temps ! HOP !
Allez elle est deg, la PLS
OOOH qu'est ce qu'il se passe mec ?! WOOOH
*Gémissement de peur virile* J'PANIQUE J'PANIQUE !
Oh merde les bougies ! Les bougies les bougies les bougies !
On s'amuse mais *Soupir* OH NON MAIS CA C'EST DE LA TRICHE CA !
Elle les déplace mec ! Elles déplace les bougies la pute !
Clément les bougies, les bougies !
Les bougies !
LES BOUGIES !
AS-TU VU ?
NON !
J'rallume ! j'rallume !
Non il me faut deux autres bougies !
Naaaaan
Naan...
Tu n'as pas réussis à t'échapper de la pièce.
On y retourne aussitôt !
*ORGUE*
C'est parti, on lance le.. le p'tit rituel !
Là, mec, on va faire les choses bien !
Ok donc la il faudrait que j'en rallume 3 sur 4
comme ça j'aurait juste à rallumer la dernière quand elle sera rentrée
ELLE EST RENTRÉE
Je ferme la fenêtre, HOP , et j'allume.. Toutes les bougies
Voila, là elle est baisée
elle fait tomber le miroir parce qu’elle est vénére .          Ça se passe bien.
Ça se passe très bien
Elle sort des chiottes ! Je tire la chasse d'eau parce-que je suis un jeune garçon insolent.
Voila. *BRUIT DE CLEF* J'ai la moitié de clef !
Et comment j'avais fait pour la deuxième partie ?
AH OUI ! Fallait bloquer la porte, HOP LA
La porte est bloquée
Donc, là elle va essayer de venir par où ?
Je crois qu'elle va essayer de péter la chaise ou un truc comme ça non ?
Elle va se vénère de ouf !
Elle va passer en mode "Mon fils à eu 3/20" J'te jure.
BLOODY MARY BLOODY MARY BLOODY MARY
ET BOUM !
... Attends y'a eu un...
...Bah y'a eu un bug.
Y'a eu un morceau de clef qu'a volé , mais il est tombé euuuh, dan le vide en fait !
Y'a eu un morceau de clef qui AH REGARDE Y'a un bug !
Y'a deux moitié de clef maintenant !
Ah d'accord fallait que je les assemble ! Super, c'est pas un bug.
Donc ça, ça se pète. Qu'est ce que je fait parce que je suis un jeune-homme insolant ?
Je la remplace
Ok la, c'est la que sa passe en mode très très très go j'aime pas du tout
c'est la qu'il va falloir trouver les bougie il faut ce concentrer
faut que je les trouve faut que je les trouve *Panique*
la! la bas! y'en à une la!
mais toi il fait n'importe quoi mec *parle au tiroire*
Nan mais clément regarde le tiroir est bugué *crie*
le tiroir il est bugué je ne peu pas ouvrir
y'en n'a pas une dedans non? Ah bas voila *deçu*
Ok cette petite Fdp *bafouille*
Il faut que je reste concentré sur les bougies
Ok elle a pété la chaise
il faut que je reste concentré sur les bougies
oh yes! y'en a deux la déjà
C'est bien ça!
y'en a une là, y'en a une là, y'en  a une en bas y'en à une en bas
Yes!!! C'est bon, c'est bon!
Une bougie, il manque une bougie, une bougie
une bougie il me manque!
ou elle est?!!! *panique* ou elle est... LA!! Oui!!!
Oui!Oui!Oui!
C'est bon! du coup il y a le dernier chiffre qui apparait ou pas? *excitation*
ouais! Bah la du coup j'ai plus qu'a taper le code
oh et j'ai un gun! et je peu lui tiré dessus!
je vais me faire plaisir mon pote!
t'es ou?! il faut que je pète le miroir?
*Tire à plusieurs reprise!*
*crie de Bloody Marry*
Je vais avoir du mal à expliqué les dégâts de la salle de bain aux parents
Je vais pas te mentir si je leurs dis j'était juste entrain
de chier il vont pas trop me croire!
voila donc la qu'est ce que tu a gagné dans cette histoire?
personne vas te croire 600 000 euro de travaux dans la salle de bain
bilan est ce que vous invoqueriez des esprits chez vous?
bah bien-sur c'est moi qui... *bafouillage*
Hé bien voila c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plus!
merci d'avoir regarder portez vous bien tchao tout le monde...
oh ça les a frustré ta vue?
Hahahaha *rire affreux*
PEAAAAAAAACE!!!!!
*musique d'intro de fin*